>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Ramon Miro: It is my
great pleasure this evening
to introduce Louise Borden.
Louise is a native of Cincinnati
where she grew up with two sisters
in what she describes as
an old house near the crest
of a steep hill, which
apparently made
for some interesting childhood
bicycle riding experiences.
Louise grew up fascinated by
stories of ordinary people
and their relationship
to historical events.
Louise caught the reading
bug in elementary school
when she discovered that her school
library contained a treasure trove
of chapter books, biographies and
stories that took her far away
to other countries and cultures.
Her school library and those shelves
of books were her happy place.
An avid reader of non-fiction and
historical fiction Louise majored
in history at Dennison University.
She worked as a teaching
assistant and later was a teacher
for young children and
realized a lifelong dream
when she became co-owner
of the Book Shelf.
A bookstore in her
hometown of Cincinnati.
In 1971, Louise married Peter
Borden in what was then,
and it was when the younger of their
two daughters started elementary
school that Louise began work
on her first children's book,
Caps, Hats, Socks and Mittens.
A book about the four seasons.
Her love of history has come
into play in many of the more
than 30 books for young readers
both fiction and non-fiction
that have followed including
His Name Was Raoul Wallenberg,
The Little Ships: The Historic
Rescue at Dunkirk, Fly High:
The Story of Bessie Coleman,
and her most recent book,
Across the Blue Pacific:
A World War II Story.
Among Louise's recent
non-fiction books is The Journey
That Saved Curious George:
The True Wartime Escape
of Margret and H.A. Rey.
A book that describes the
remarkable partnership of the Reys
and their dramatic escape
from war torn Europe
to build a new life in America.
This book is especially timely
because this September marks the
75th birthday of Curious George,
and I believe this evening Louise
will be discussing the story
of the Reys and how her
research during her travels led
to her writing The Journey
That Saved Curious George.
So now please join me in
welcoming Louise Borden.
[ Applause ]
>> Louise Borden: Thank you so much.
Thank you so much, Ramon.
Thank you.
What a nice introduction.
I wish my mom were here, you know,
because all of my life
wasn't like that.
[Laughter] But anyway thank you.
So, gosh, we've got bright
lights here and everything.
And I'm kind of a casual speaker so
I'll be walking around a little bit,
and I'm going to show you some
visuals, but it's a real thrill
to be at this amazing place
of books, so many readers,
and I just met a woman from
California who came all the way
to attend the Book Festival.
My husband and I lived in the
DC area for 5 years between 2007
and 2013, and I was a big fan
of the Library of Congress.
I lived there.
While my husband would go
to work, I would go to work
at a desk at the Library.
So, it's a thrill to be part
of this great organization
that is sponsoring
the Book Festival.
So I think we'll turn my slide,
okay, the slides are on, and yes,
I have written many books,
but I feel like The Journey
That Saved Curious George is
one of my most important books
because I was a path finder and
had to show you where the Reys went
when they escaped during World
War II and came to America
as immigrants, which is
really a telling story,
it's an American story, and we
have so many immigrants coming now
with energy and hope and creativity
just like Margret and Hans.
So I'm going to step away from this
and kind of walk around down here.
And we have this beautiful poster
that was designed and the theme
of this year's festival is
Journey Into the Unknown,
and I'm going to take you
on two journeys tonight.
Thank you, Library of Congress.
Oh, there's George as a reader.
Even George is our reader isn't he?
He's 75 years old this year.
Isn't that just remarkable?
So, Curious George, Allan Drummond,
the illustrator of the book,
and I all welcome you to the story
behind George's publication 75
years ago.
Here's our team, readers,
writers, artists
and detectives from
all across the US.
Indeed, George inspires all
of us to celebrate curiosity.
So, join two journeys with us.
Now remember today is
September 24, 2016.
So I want you to become
detectives as we learn
where George was 76 years ago today.
Was he in France?
Was he in Spain?
Was he in Portugal?
Was he in Brazil?
Was he in the United States?
Let's find out.
So as Ramon told you, I
grew up in Cincinnati.
I was the middle of three
girls, no boys in our family,
but we were very curious kids.
And I went off to elementary
school and I was familiar
with the Curious George books.
You can tell I went to school in the
50s when the pictures were in black
and white and one of my classmates
is here today, Beth Fatheringill.
I didn't show our first
grade picture, Beth,
but we went to the
same elementary school,
and she is a wonderful librarian
here in DC at John Eaton School.
So when we were little girls,
we were reading Curious George,
Curious George Rides a Bike,
but I had no clue what the H
and the A stood for in H.A. Rey.
I got older, went to high
school, went to college
and once summer I took a bicycle
trip as part of a study group.
I was in Europe for six weeks
and notice what my notice,
who was also on the trip,
and a friend are wearing.
They're not wearing sneakers,
they're not wearing Nikes,
they're not wearing athletic gear,
you know, we're wearing skirts,
flats and just had a few
belongings on our bicycles.
And during college, I was
studying World War II.
I was especially interested
in resistance movements,
the European response to Hitler in
various countries including France.
So I knew that millions of refugees
had been displaced during World
War II.
My life unfolded, I got
married, we had kids,
I began writing children's
books and here I am
in my office typing probably
an email to one of my editors.
And these are the subjects
I like to write about,
but World War II is
obviously one of my favorites.
I've written six books
about the war.
So people say how did you find
the story that Curious George was
in a manuscript on a bicycle and
when the Reys' escaped from Paris?
I said, well, in 1995, I read
an article in Publisher's Weekly
and it was about famous
children's book authors
and illustrators including the
Reys and Margret Rey stated
that she had escaped with her
husband on a bicycle in June
of 1940 carrying the
manuscript for George.
I said, wow.
So I looked at a map of France and
I said which road did they follow
from Paris down to the border?
They must have been on
a train part of the way.
Were they in danger?
What happened to their belongings?
What were they doing in France?
And I had this image of them
in a sea of refugees, unknown,
not wealthy, not famous, but just
on, working artists on the road
to safety getting out of
the way of the German Army.
At the same time that I learned
about the Reys' escape from Paris,
I was working on a book called
The Little Ships about the rescue
at Dunkirk, again, June 1940.
So, I had done a lot of
background reading on that.
In 1998, Houghton Mifflin, the
publisher of Curious George,
published the original Watercolors,
and when I saw this book
and I saw right here it
says H.A. Rey, Paris,
January 1940, I said bingo.
He was in Paris, but the Curious
George copies that you've read
in your libraries don't have
that little signature on it.
Just the original Watercolor.
So, sometimes you're a path finder
when you're telling a true story
because no one has
been there before you.
No book had been written
about the Reys.
They were no longer living,
they didn't have children,
so I embarked on my journey of
research going to the University
of Southern Mississippi
where there's a collection
of children's literature and after
the Reys died every photograph,
royalty statement, letter went
down to this special archive.
It had not been cataloged
when I got there.
Now if you go, it's online,
it's in boxes, but I just kind
of started going through stacks
of these newly arrived materials
as an amateur detective, and I had
to piece together the facts
of this wartime escape.
I learned about H.A.'s life.
Hmm. As a detective,
he's smoking a pipe.
Doesn't the man with a
yellow hat smoke a pipe?
I learned that H is for
Hans, that A is for Augusto.
I learned that Margret Rey was a
photographer and an artist, and hmm,
looks like she's standing
on a balcony.
Are there any kids in
the audience what season
of the year do you think
that picture was taken?
Do you think it was
taken in the summer?
Yeah. In winter, why
do you think that?
Because there's now on the balcony.
So as a research detective,
we use our eyes looking
at these old photographs.
I learned that they were
both born in Hamburg, German.
It's a northern city in Germany,
lots of boats, lots of bridges,
and that both families,
Margret's and Han's, were Jewish.
I learned that after World
War I Hans left Germany
because of inflation and the
terrible economy, went to Brazil
and he was there for 10 years
and them Margret left Germany
because of the rise of Hitler and
she knew that Hans, a family friend,
was in Rio, and he was a
brilliant artist as she was.
So she went over and
connected with Hans there
and they became Brazilian
citizens because in Germany
if you were Jewish, you
lost your citizenship.
So it was very important to
have those Brazilian passports.
They got married in 1935
and then in 1936 they went
to Paris on a belated honeymoon.
In the archive, I found tiny
little calendar books the size
of those yellow Post-Its that
we use that Hans wrote and many
of these were written in
French, many of the pages.
I also looked at letters written
in French to and from his editor.
I looked at addresses.
Here it says monsieur, that
means mister, H.A. Rey,
Chateau Forgau [phonetic].
And I looked at the
date, October 1939.
A chateau.
Were they staying in a
chateau on their honeymoon?
I thought they were staying
in a hotel on their honeymoon.
Hmm. Maybe I could call up my
old high school French teacher,
who had been born in Paris and
lived during the occupation
in Saint-Tropez in
the south of France.
She was still alive, still
speaking English and French.
Maybe I could call
up Rene Lauder people
and she could help me translate
some of these documents.
Then I found French identity
cards in the archive.
Well, look at this.
It's kind of like a
driver's license isn't it?
Hans had to sign his name.
Hans Augusto Reyersbach.
Reyersbach.
Hmm. I thought the
guy's name was H.A. Rey.
When did he change his
name from Reyesbach to Rey
and why did he change his name?
I learned that their first
book that Margret and Hans did
in Paris was called Raffy and
the Nine Monkeys in French
and it was also published
in London in English.
More letters I had to
go through detailing all
of their book work while
they were living in Paris.
And then I found this
photograph of Hans.
Hmm. Looks like he's losing
his hair like my husband.
All the archives are
black and white photos,
but the color that I saw
was Hans's art and then
when I saw this painting that he had
done at the age of 8 titled Horses
In The Park, I thought bingo.
I'm going to use that to bring
the reader into the story
and start the book with Hans
as a little boy growing
up in Hamburg, Germany.
Here's a telegram, have had a very
narrow escape, baggage all lost.
Signed Rey.
Amazing no one had
dusted off the history
until I was curious
about their escape.
I realized that in those
little calendar books
if I could enlarge them on a
Xerox machine and translate them,
that Hans was going to tell
me day by day where he went
on their escape from Paris.
Here it says this is June 12
left Paris at 5:30 by bicycle
to ETomp [phonetic] a town
about 25 miles south of Paris.
So a working title
was where I began.
My titles usually change
and the True Escape
of Curious George is still kind
of the title I think
of this book as having.
I went to the Terrass Hotel where
the Reys spent their honeymoon
and then ended up living
in the hotel
for four years using
my passport, of course.
As the writer, you want to find the
best details to draw the readers in.
A young reader and
also adult readers
because the Reys' story
is for all of us.
You listen for a word or phrase
from people you meet along the way.
People who were there.
You listen to their story.
This is Jean-Max Hurand, who was
the owner of the Terrass Hotel.
He was 10 years old when
the Nazis came into Paris,
and told me about his
family's story.
As a detective, you
rent a car in Paris
and you head south on narrow roads.
Sometimes you're gripping
the steering wheel.
So I took a car whereas
the Reys were on bicycles,
but I was looking for that chateau.
You take a train to the same
station that Hans noted in his diary
to follow in the Reys'
traveled footsteps.
You write to your own
editor from those places
as you piece together the
quilt of an unknown story.
You uncover the roads and the
history a kilometer at a time.
You finally arrive in
your second rental car.
Oh, it looks a little
shabby doesn't it?
I drove up the road and found
this amazingly beautiful chateau
where the Reys spent three months in
the fall of 1939 working on a book
about a curious little monkey
named Fifi who had a friend,
the man with the yellow hat.
The window there is a room in one
of the three towers of the chateau.
It's the only room in the tower
and the owner told me that,
that there were no other rooms and
Hans noted in his, in the archives
that he set up a studio in
the tower of this chateau.
So, as a detective, sometimes
I live my life in color
and sometimes I live my
life in black and white.
But, of course, I'm writing
a book in the 21st Century.
This is a kid who lives in
Laktour [phonetic], the little town
where Hans noted in his
diary that he bought paint
and paper for his art work.
In the section of the Reys' escape
leaving the country of France going
over the border into
Spain, here are these,
these are 21st Century readers and
fishermen on the coastal towns.
I wasn't able to go but I sent a
friend of mine and he connected
with two Spaniards, a France
translator and driver.
They explored the border towns
in their car with the man
with the orange hat, my
husband, Pete Borden.
So he was my detective,
my research detective.
So on these two journeys
into the unknown,
the Reys had help along the way
during their escape and I, too,
had help along the
way in my research.
So when I signed a contract for this
book, I signed a two book contract,
which was unusual for me and fun,
and the other book was called
Across the Blue Pacific.
So I had finished the text for the
Journey that Saved Curious George
so I was then working
on Blue Pacific
and it was the illustrator's
turn to work on the Journey
That Saved Curious George.
Allan Drummond, who
lives in England.
So the book was finally
published in 2005 in hard cover;
it came out in 2010 in paperback.
And I loved opening the book and
my favorite part is the end paper
with the map and I was able
to draw the line and show you
where they went from
Paris down through Spain
and Portugal to get to Lisbon.
So back to being detectives
and we're looking
for September 24th aren't we?
Remember that, 1940?
The first part of the book is
two artists, the childhood,
the Hamburg years and
then we're going
to fast forward to
escape from Paris.
They left Paris on June
12, 1940, on two bicycles
that Hans cobbled together
from spare parts because all
of the bicycles had been
sold out in the store.
And that image I had in my head
Allan just drew beautifully of them
on the long road with
all of these refugees.
Sometimes you don't need words;
an image conveys that story.
So, June 13 they were
sleeping in a farm.
June 18 to 20 they were on the road
carrying those Brazilian passports
with them.
They arrived in Lisbon, the
capital of Portugal, on June 23.
And I got this address from one of
their letters and my friend, Beth,
my good friend the librarian
from John Eaton School,
was in Portugal recently and I
asked her to go to that address
and take a picture for me.
So on July 21, they board a ship,
the Angola, they leave Lisbon,
on August 4 they arrive in Rio
where they lived that August and all
of September waiting for a visa.
They leave Rio on October 3, 1940,
and I found the ship manifest
and they arrived in New York on
October 14, 1940, in New York City.
So where were they on September 24?
Do you remember?
They were in Rio, Brazil,
where we just had the Olympics.
Oops. Sorry.
I hit the wrong button there.
Okay. So they were in Rio.
Imagine a world without
Curious George
or the wonderful art of H.A. Rey.
In late September 1940, three months
after the Reys escaped from Paris
and while they were waiting in Rio,
a Nazi ordinance required
all foreign Jews living
in the occupied zone to
register at police stations.
Beginning in June 1941, thousands
of foreign Jews were deported
from France to Hitler's death camps.
On August 17, 1941, in America,
Curious George was
published by Houghton Mifflin.
Margret and Hans were lucky and they
left Europe before the full horror
and tragic events of
the Holocaust unfolded.
So Houghton Mifflin, Allan
and I have made this new
young reader's edition.
It's smaller than the original
book, as a birthday gift to George
with a new become a detective
section at the end of the book
so we can share kind of
the excitement of research
and get kids excited about that too.
In October, the complete adventures,
the seven original books,
will be published including a
scrap book 20-page retrospective
that I wrote for kids
at the end of that book.
What would Margret and Hans say
about their remarkable
legacy to all of us?
I think they would just be
thrilled at what has happened
in the last 75 years with
their curious little monkey.
George is certainly our ambassador
for reading around the world
and I really love, this is one
of my favorite illustrations,
because they're coming down that
gang plank holding those important
travel documents, those passports.
So I've made passports with kids in
schools and put visa stamps in them.
I think of all the people coming
to our country now
with those passports.
And here these readers
are at the beginning
of wonderful book journeys.
Some day they will be coming to
this wonderful Book Festival.
New work is an unknown
journey for me.
Each book always has its own voice,
but writing about kindergarten
and baseball is different
from writing about war.
So, I kind of have to plant my pole
and right now I'm back on a story
about World War II, and I
did a lot of that research
at this beautiful Library of
Congress where we were last night.
And when I get a little
discouraged, I think of Hans.
I look at his sketches, I
look at their identity cards,
and I go back to Paris and hang
out with Jean-Max at the Terrass.
His hotel will always hold
echoes of long ago years.
Indeed, the courage of the Reys
and George is always with me
on my new writing adventures.
And now I'm sure Margret and Hans
would agree it's time to head
to dinner and George is
telling us that it's the end.
So, we might have time
for a question or two.
Where is my timekeeper?
Oh, right there.
Okay. So, there we go.
[ Applause ]
So, does anyone have a question
or I've been yammering at you
and it's late in the day and you've
been listening to 50 other authors.
So, any questions?
Here we go.
>> Well, the last time
we connected was an email
that I sent to you as you were --
>> Louise Borden: Are you James?
>> Yes.
>> Louise Borden: Nice
to meet you, James.
Thank you.
Dr. James Hughes.
>> Thank you.
Just a beautiful tapestry and
just the amount of enormous effort
on your part is just so appreciated.
So, thank you.
>> Louise Borden: Thank
you very much.
And go Nats.
You've got your Nats cap on.
Yeah. Okay.
>> I have one question.
>> Louise Borden: Oh, sure.
>> Was anything on this long
journey that shocked you
and actually maybe even
upset you that you found out?
>> Louise Borden: Uhm, I don't think
anything shocked me or upset me,
but I learned some things about
Margret and Hans and I just fell
in love with them, but Hans
was a man of great habit
and Margret was very
energetic and kind
of the rambunctious one of the two.
And I notice that in
their handwriting too.
And so I would look at
little details like that.
Also when I'm looking at the
research, it's all black and white,
but you know, people were living
this in color and I think when kids
and even adults when we
look at those old photos,
we just see this black and white
world, but that great exodus
of 5 million people on the road,
it was in living full color.
And so, you know, I
think about that a lot.
And, yes, I had some
connections too,
you know, they lost my suitcase.
I only had my backpack,
it was pouring rain,
it was 5 in the morning and I
said, oh, I'm in total Rey mode.
So I had a lot of kind of fun, and I
lost a few things along the way too.
>> I'm curious because
obviously they've done
such a wonderful children's
book you mentioned
that the Reys didn't have children.
>> Louise Borden: Right, right.
>> Did you find anything in your
research that indicated why?
>> Louise Borden: They
didn't have children.
Okay, so in 1940, Hans
is 42 years old
and they're just beginning
World War II.
Margret was younger.
They just, I don't know if
it's because they didn't want
to have children or they couldn't
have children, but they didn't
but they certainly have the
children of the world and, you know,
there's a lot of working
artists/writers
who don't have children and they
devote themselves to their art so.
But they saved everything and it's
all at the [inaudible] Collections.
So, you know, maps and
pottery that Margret made.
And so artifacts are so
important for us now looking back.
So, that's why these
libraries are just,
you know, living treasures for us.
Well, thank you very much.
I've got two minutes left.
So I'll let you guys
take that two minutes
and go buy a book, all right?
[Laughter] Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thank you, Iris.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.